what about people that rely too much on
somebody else taking them where they
want to go so that's the thing it's
finding that balance because I see that
I definitely see the dome workaholics
and then I see also the flip side of the
people that maybe they got a great
degree in something and they're not
utilizing it they have such great talent
and they hold themselves back well there
is again a trust that there's a reason
why they're doing that you know it
really that that has building an
ensemble that lesson is one of the
hardest lessons that I had to learn is
that what I see in someone their
potential or maybe one element of their
creativity one element of their passion
does not encompass them as a whole and
it you have to respect the fact that you
will see potential in people that they
do not want to live up to they may even
want to say they want to live up to it
they may want to plea realize that
there's value in that potential they get
it they see it and they realize that
society places a value on it so they
will highlight it but they won't put in
the work that it takes to develop it I
almost never and and this is you know
there's a lot of actors who follow me on
the internet and this is something you
guys need to know I almost never work
with an actor who has not been
performing for 20 years well tena you're
working with some very young actors yep
Gerard marzulli and Danielle k jones
started performing when they were five
years old professionally they have been
on stage every freakin day four hours a
day at least putting into that study of
conflict that we were talking about
earlier all the time they are masters of
their craft and in another 20 years they
will be legends and ultimately that is
what keeps my interest that's what keeps
me challenged because they are masters
that should terrify a director I you
know it should that's the point that's
the fun and if you haven't you know if
you have it you know if you if you
haven't been in combat for for for ten
years they're not going to ask you if
you want to get on a special ops team
you're not going to get sent in to
Beirut and
told that it's a secret and no one can
ever find out you're there because you
don't have the skills like it's a craft
it's a craft that has to be developed
and developed and developed talent is
overrated Gerard has a great story he's
studied every kind of acting style under
the Sun good thing with some notable
exceptions that he's working on you know
but um but he loves to tell the story of
and so this is like fourth hand forgive
me if I have this wrong but Robert
Duvall was studying Meisner at the same
time that guys like Al Pacino were was
it mines near sanford meisner i think it
was but forgive me this is take it with
a grain of salt guys bottom line he
shows up in class and the teacher
Meisner is like well I just I'm not I'm
not seeing it in the audition I'm not
seeing it the audition I'm sorry I can't
and Robert Falls like you've got to let
me take this class this is all I can do
I don't I'm gonna wash your toilets I
will I will clean this theater every day
all day it's going to be spotless all
I'm asking is for four hours of your
time when class is in session I'll sit
in the back and I'll do my work and and
Meisner said well you better freaking do
the work you'd better show up you'd
better be the most prepared kid in class
you know what I mean ten years later my
eyes are saying well that Robert Duvall
sure worked hard ah you know what I mean
and I work with actors who who made
themselves talent talent just is like a
little percentage that determines how
long it's going to take you to become
good at something and it's not going to
skew more than ten or twenty percent in
any direction you know if you love
acting you've got the tools to be a
great actor you've just you've literally
got to make it a lifestyle choice
acknowledge the fact that you're going
to be making some huge sacrifices and
other parts of your life to make it work
and then dig in and build those school
then you know some kid shows up in Los
Angeles and he worked in modeling and
he's very spunky and he's very energetic
I bet you I bet you right away I'll see
he doesn't speak from his diaphragm I
bet you're right away I'll see that he's
he's not as smooth and lie
and he doesn't have as many characters
in his body his movement training is
lacking his voice training is lacking he
doesn't have the tools turn around and
look at an actor like George Clooney or
Meryl Streep one of those actors
everyone wants to be even that kid who
shows up from New York remodeling wants
to be George Clooney does because George
Clooney's super cool why is he cool
because he has the fundamentals to
reinvent himself he doesn't ever need to
be the same person two days in a row
ever because he has so many skills and
so many honed crafts he could walk out
of the door and be an old man one day
and a young man the next and he could be
any any different number of George
Clooney's that he wants to be and when
he runs into a wall in his career and
people don't want to cast of his ex or
why he's like a football player he
doesn't even know there's a wall there
he just rolls right around it you know
he just slips right around it like the
walls not even there like like he's a
river over the rocks just whoosh and now
George Clooney's making another movie
with Steven Soderbergh about something
else why fun of malice cuz he can
because he's got eight gazillion tools
and just he doesn't matter didn't even
notice that there's a hammer missing ah
keep the hammer I'll move on I'll build
my couch anyway
you